[Applause]
my first guest tonight is the editor of
Martha Stewart Living magazine and
tomorrow night you can see the Martha
Stewart Living Halloween special on
stations across the country please
welcome a one-woman conglomerate Martha
Stewart now you're going to basically be
showing us things that we can do to
spice up Halloween's all right yes
because I think Halloween is just for me
it's the most fun hollow holiday right
did you get to make a lot of stuff well
we do and we like to scare people right
okay okay what's the I don't think
you're very you know I don't think
you're very prone to being scared no no
no I've seen it all I'm a really tough
guy I think you're jaded yeah yeah I'm a
real jaded Hollywood professional so why
don't you cut a turnip what is this yeah
little turnips that are hollowed out
yeah and they make these cute little
lanterns and you can put them you can
hang them in the trees you know only
only Martha Stewart is dissatisfied with
a pumpkin you know everyone else is like
a pumpkins fine you're like no no a
turnip
well turnips are actually traditional
for All Hallows Eve this was in the
olden days when they didn't have
pumpkins right before anyone had fun on
how exactly and they used to carry
little coals and these little pumpkins
and uh to ward off the evil spirit and
it would go from house to house and
throw dirt on each other exactly and try
to get some get a pointer to it was a
better time than so you can carve out
your turnips it's fun now all these
recipes I want to point out are in my
new healthy quick cook oh okay I bet
that's for sale all of these I mean it's
available all around the country and
no it's not available oh that's a joke
okay none of these recipes are in that
book right I'm just joking right
but I mean carving a turnip that's
insane they're carving huh the pumpkin
carving poco a knife on me yeah that's a
little saw why don't you try carving a
little face in the hand hollowed-out
pumpkin and while you do that I will
what are you get doing over there oh
that's terrible what I just made well it
looks like a turnip has been in a
horrible accident there isn't that great
look at that look what I made isn't that
really cute actually use a pumpkin next
time knock
only an idiot uses a turnip pot alright
this we should move on quickly what do
we have over here you want a job well
yes give me a job to decorate this owl
now you have all the icings and the owls
and the bat cookies are very hard but
you can is so good you can flood what do
you do I draw something now no this pole
flooding to make it all beautiful and
smooth like that so here's the initial
cookie right here's from this cutter
like that yes from a cook which is
available everywhere yes and so is then
you thought the cookie with this icing
right here to create a sort of base and
then you can flock it what what are you
laughing at nothing happened there
what's a little toy I just wrote it okay
don't worry I'm gonna put a little face
on okay you put face and then I will
flock it with this beautiful granulated
sugar okay I'm very good at this
yes I'm very very talented in the
kitchen what are you doing don't sugar
on my cookie okay why are you like that
[Applause]
that's so rude and it's so rude I'm busy
working and sub meet you throwing sugar
all over the place just trying to
demonstrate a technique Kony you don't
get so violent well I get angry
sometimes these are beautiful these ones
that were made with these made weeks ago
no be honest were made today for you you
can actually eat it if you want what do
you think very good yeah
okay so then you can do these beautiful
Lumina pumpkins this is a pumpkin it's
me that's you weren't it's something a
face here at all there's a decoration
this is to be another Lantern again you
don't have to do it and so is that
beautiful Hubbard just eased for the
diseased look of your pumpkin oh and
then this is our root beer floats - and
why is it steaming like well there is
dry ice underneath and we need some hot
water I wish we had some hot water here
and this is just to serve in the
cauldron and what happened the kids come
by with their plastic pumpkin and you
dump this into it is that what's the
idea here the whole thing I know you
give it to them at the door if they do
an extra special treat for you and is
the idea really that this is very good
but I think somewhat ice will start to
activate you have to keep activating it
with hot water or you know the spoon or
carbon death there's dry ice in there
yes there is is not ice just got in my
throat no no strict in air passage
[Applause]
he's okay no no all better now
you'd like to be very scary on Halloween
Conan yeah scary Z is great so we have
these scary masks and this mask is
covering an even scarier mask look at
this
oh cool just just release
that's our dead head coming do you like
him
how much do you pay that guy he makes
six hundred thousand dollars a year to
go boo you do this is this something you
would actually do for kids is put out oh
yes I think it's so much fun and the
kids and the kids
really
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right eyebrows
oh this guy's gonna beat the crap out of
me during the commercial break he's
gonna stand up really taste it tastes
good didn't it yes it did my thank you
sorry you threw it on the floor I
enjoyed it and I'm looking forward to
purchasing the recipe soon at a store
near me uh we can't thank you enough for
coming here and showing us all this
stuff it's always fun to have you on the
program fun to be here and I I do hope
that you um you do open your door on
Halloween to the all the neighborhood
children right of course I love kids
okay what do you can harm what-what are
you gonna give them I just I have well
this is I'll use this stuff no we didn't
I'm just telling to grab a couple of
barrels of this after the show's over
and I'll say here kids was on TV and
throw it at him and you'll be there too
stinky
all right we're uh we're out of time but
thank you very much best of luck with
the special purpose to it everybody very
funny guy Jim Owen is coming out we'll
take a break